ragazzi miei siamo tornati su 100 floors
non lo dirò mai giusto il nome fino alla
fine della serie continua siamo arrivati
al piano 75 in teoria dovremmo arrivare
al 100 oggi però non ne sono sicuro dopo
si aspetta era diventato verde ma sei
scema diventi verde quando hai voglia
con quale fisica non è possibile ma di
là e vabbè livello 76
dobbiamo farne 25 forma entro oggi ve lo
giuro io sono sicuro che se lo fai qua
no mi chiedo riordina sto coso nora gav
e prego io comunque essendo uno youtuber
o dei limiti tipo questo è un limite ve
lo assicuro devo farlo diventare un
quadrato cuadrado ma sei scemo dai da
c'è un maledetto pezzo al contrario ma
porca vacca come ho fatto con forte
anche se come si fa in casa o no ma va a
cagare va 12 ore per fatto livello
maledizione va avanti
77 ci arriveremo alla 100 prima o poi lo
so io lo sento
non ho capito cosa ho fatto ma andiamo
avanti lo stesso
vabbè mi chiedo fra il cubo novero si è
scemo allora punto interrogativo rivolto
verso l'alto l'ora in alto qua c'è il
nero per forza allora
fin qui è ok vuol dire che il bianco
visto che a sinistra del rosso però il
rovescio per l'ipotenusa il marrone e il
blu per bluffa cioè po scagliato fa e
marrone che è stato qua no
lavorava il contrario blu e marco blu e
marrone grazie as
devo fare questo ma voi siete scemi che
qua in teoria sì per ora è impossibile
e questo parcam h amate mongoloide gesù
vai avanti 80 all'ora questo e va beh
rivale mandato da scoperchiare la tomba
di gesù perfetto devono darci fuoco per
schiacciare il tasto pure allora 132
ah ho capito allora 132 quindi 113 e 2
questo quindi 13 25 40 53
al contrario 33 25 40 53 arca vacca
fenomeno poi era questa questa era
abbastanza semplice c'è stato
sono stati momenti più difficili della
mia vita mi india meno male che è
tornata la matematica mi mancava e la
tabellina del 9 quindi siamo al piano 81
9x9 81
hai visto come ha funzionato ho già
capito che così non sapevo che era così
mentre che sbagliavo ci sono arrivato
oggi al telefono
l'occhio del drago ma manca un coso non
so se eccolo là grazie
devo metterli in una posizione giusta
devo far di punta e la stato trovato qui
aiuto sto trovando cose che non si pò
meglio ma non ho capito
ecco qua c'è un buco a fan cuore vuote
né alla mano non so capace ha fatto così
insieme 83 sì ma tu sei drogato una
morte ma non sono mai stato bravo che le
formine
[Musica]
no perché io con la mia modesta
esperienza so fare cose tipo evocare
satana in questo momento 213 31 112
avevo da fogassi cosi a e come prima
come quello di prima di tomba di gesù
213 poi 3 1 1 1 2 di essa 86
questo mi sembra una cagata però è un po
strano che sia una cagata para 11 a ok
ti dice il senso alla 11 verso sinistra
ecco visto come ho già sbagliato 11 5 in
senso orario 51 io da buon scassinatore
lo stavo facendo nel modo c'è lo stavo
facendo come scassinato una cassaforte 8
e antiorario e 12 orario lyse dovere mi
scusi scusi devo andare
ti do fuoco ti do un machete salve
ci troviamo dal cazzo è molto gentile no
cos'è forse non hai capito
nardo fuoco o bravo vuol dire che no non
sto capendo il problema nel togliersi
dalle palle mentre io chiamo magagna
togliti togliti maledetto orson schifose
in miniatura
facciamo più casino russando ce l'ho
fatta
un genio dovevo togliere l'audio lo
sapevo io in fondo lo sapevo è qualcosa
dovevo fare perché mi dicevano 88 a dove
infila la palla nei cilindri lorca vacca
amazon cilindro a dopo ok capisco e gli
accesi tutti no a farsi da questa fosse
presa ok perfetto 89 forse ci arriva a
100 e non sono sicuro ma forse sì
stavo scherzando mi hanno messo in mezzo
breaking bad quando non dovevano farlo
[Musica]
cosa
devo trovare un altro puntino blu con
questo per accenderli tutti che devo
trovare la combinazione di tutti per
cliccare questo scommettete certo
accende di tutti tranne quello e poi
schiacciarlo solo che non so ecco a
carissimo dovevo studiarmi la posizione
dei si o livaja caso se i livelli o non
li fai faccio il pennello qui faccio un
16 qua lo vedete c'è un 16 a rosa verde
e giusto cioè per me è giusto per te non
ho prove o era contrario bene è una
carriera questo era abbastanza
complicato vai
grazie per avermi fatto l'esame della
vista ci vedo aziende dove c'è il
ragionamento è meglio fare a caso prima
o poi succederà qualcosa tipo adesso
gesù 90 o grazie avermi ricordato
livello a2 schiacciarli tipo 39 secondi
giusto
l'orologio di secondi non rimane quello
di windows acceso ok col timer ciò 129
da 123 no
123 a e giusto
dopo il time out uno guarda quello del
computer malizia allora c'è scritto 11
di sopra a xx i numeri romani
pagatissima 11 come si scrive e si
aggiustano questo deve essere ok per
berbatov a 99 95
porca 8 26
[Applauso]
no non l'ho capito questo giuro non l'ho
capito questo giuro non l'ho capito
anche anche in altri non ho capito ma
questo peggio questo c'erano troppe cose
non potevo farlo a caso c'è una
probabilità su un miliardo sopra tutti i
100 livelli questo che ho capito meno
non ho capito niente però ok
meno male perché quando sapevo dove
sbattere la testa rega giuro ok questo
mi chiamo che si confrontano a cagata
incredibile oh mio dio
oh mio dio o ci ho messo un'ora per far
farò la sma una cagata allucinante cioè
nessun ora non so perché 98 signori non
sono 97 scusate invece sotto palloncino
che non capisco il senso brucia
eccolo sete cosa 73 57 35
io devo inserire il numero mancante
allora 30 e 235 735 30 è uguale a 2 per
3x5 trovare quanto vale 735
va bene scomponiamo 5 per 7x7 per tre
allora va a cagare come aspettati
piccolo 3577 signori che problemi avete
voi con la matematica ma basta no a ceva
guardando guarda 4906 tregua da 466 65 a
qua c'è un numero 51 siete al 44 perché
è formato da quattro trattini il 9 forma
trovano 2 3 4 5 6 trattino che quindi il
5 formato da 1 2 3 4 5 con i 5 1 è
formato da 27 formato da tre tacchette
lotto è formato da e vabbè 1234567
parcheggi e 2 formato da abbia detto
prima 45 minchia 99 se dio vuole no
matematica non matematica non matematica
t'ammazzo devo arrivare a mettere 15 ma
figurati se io nella mia vita a posso
fare anche le quattro amiche alle
equazioni 3x3 per 39 più quattro
non c'è più non scoprire chi è meno come
ho fatto con omesso ho messo almeno a
quel meno vaffan cuore erano nascosti mi
chiedi ce la stanno schiacciando a caso
a ok allora bene tre più tre minchia
erano nascosti ma visti a 4 pollici 4x3
fattori cp3 fatti 15 è uguale quindi
quindi ci vuole per quattro più o meno 5
e meno prof
prof di matematica delle superiori
professore io non ho mai dato
soddisfazioni nella vita e lo so lo so
lo so che non ho mai provare di questo
video la prego
la prego mi dia un sei a posto di quei
due perché me lo merito cioè non solo
papa sta roba anche i prof mio prof mi
nascondeva di più o meno dentro la
verifica non mi faceva mentre porca
vacca centesimo livello siamo per
scoprire il centesimo livello come fatto
incredibile qualcuno mi spiega cosa
significa sta roba
cos'è sta roba
c'è una cartina stranissima e ci sono
dei simboli stranissimi questa roba
ci sono dei pallini che sono abbastanza
inutili ci sono presenti ovunque
questi pallini qui non mi convincono c'è
qualcosa di strano cioè non sapevo
potevo contarli tipo non c'è un qualche
cosa che non vedono anche concetto di
lama dopo anche quanti ce ne sono qua
aveva comprato a contarli zitti tutti
allora 1